[Music]
as donald trump faces a drop
in popularity with female voters it was
queue the first lady
one of the very few to mention the
pandemic
at this convention and she grasped the
nettle
i want to acknowledge the fact that
since march
our lives have changed drastically the
invisible enemy
kovite 19 swept across our beautiful
country
and impacted all of us
my deepest sympathy goes out to everyone
that you treat people with respect four
years ago melania trump's speech was
overshadowed by a plagiarism scandal
my parents impressed on me the values
that you work hard for what you want in
life
barack and i were raised with so many of
the same values
like you work hard for what you want in
life
speaking of strength and determination
this time her chief of staff
said every word came from her and it
felt
very personal i'm here because we need
my husband to be our president
and commander-in-chief for four more
years
he is what is best for our country
we all know donald trump makes no
secrets
about how he feels about things
total honesty is what we as citizens
deserve from our president
other moments of the convention felt far
less conventional
donald trump presiding over a
naturalization ceremony
where five people were made american
citizens
candidates for naturalization please
raise your right hand
breaking with his anti-immigration
stance
and breaking with protocol using the
white house
as a backdrop for the convention in
keeping with this controversial theme
mike pompeo delivered a speech from
jerusalem
delivering on this duty to keep us safe
and our freedoms intact
this president has led bold initiatives
in nearly every corner of the world
[Music]
a president under pressure and a first
lady
who's come out fighting putting on a
united front
in a bid for re-election sally lockwood
sky news